salud en directo américa de france 24 y
como no vamos a hablar hoy vamos a
dedicar todo este segmento de salud y
también de invitado el día con nuestro
doctor sobre el sida marc bienvenida muy
buen día feliz miércoles para usted hoy
se conmemora como ya lo dijimos entonces
el día internacional de la lucha contra
el sida 40 años después de que se
detectaran los primeros casos para
empezar cuál es la diferencia entre el
vih/sida que parece que todo el mundo lo
tiene claro pero la verdad es que no
tanto no y además es una confusión que
puede llevar a partes de discriminación
también o de estigma alrededor de la
enfermedad entonces es mejor que que lo
diferenciamos fueron por un lado el vih
es el virus de inmunodeficiencia humanos
del virus que contagia a las personas
que ataca el sistema inmune de estas
personas y que pues una persona puede
tener vih y no llegar a desarrollar el
sida el sida es la enfermedad que viene
después de tener vih no haberlo tratado
no haberlo controlado y es una condición
pues que puede presentar puede hacer que
las personas se contagie de otras
infecciones por ejemplo y el cuerpo no
lo pueda combatir por estar
inmunosuprimido también se asocia con
algunos tipos de cáncer y lo que es muy
importante es que actualmente con los
tratamientos que existen es muy posible
tener vih tener el virus sin desarrollar
sida y también incluso raúl sin
contagiar lo mar ahora le pregunto cuál
es la magnitud y del alcance de este
virus y esta enfermedad pues vamos a
repasar si te parece las cifras
generales del mundo en 2020 se
contabilizaban más de 37 millones de
personas contagiadas con vih dos tercios
de estas personas viven en el continente
africano además los contagios nuevos por
vih fueron 1,5 millones también en 2020
y las muertes vinculadas al sida es
decir a la enfermedad desarrollada a
raíz del vih fueron 680 mil américa
latina no es un continente que esté
exento también una región que no esté
exenta de este problema de salud pública
en 2019 se contabilizaron 120 mil
contagios nuevos lo que supuso un
aumento del 20% respecto al 2010 la
buena noticia es que las muertes si
descendieron descendieron un 10 por
ciento y también en 2019 esta enfermedad
del sida se cobró la vida de 37 mil
personas
puede impedir el contagio cuál es la
manera más efectiva de no contraer vih
pues eso es muy importante que lo
hablemos y de hecho yo creo que te va a
responder el mejor oscar franco que nos
acompaña pues en todo esto este especial
segmento de salud el epidemiólogo y
director del instituto de medicina de
salud pública de la universidad de berna
doctor muy buenos días y muchas gracias
por acompañarnos por ahora el sida sigue
siendo una enfermedad que no tiene cura
entonces imagino que la mejor prevención
es evitar el contagio cómo se contagia
el vih cómo podemos evitarlo
correcto y marc si me permites te cuento
un poco acerca del día mundial de acción
contra el sida
este día empieza en 1987 unos
trabajadores de la organización mundial
de la salud deciden que es fundamental
tener un día en el que recordemos y
conmemoramos todas las vidas que se han
perdido casi 40 millones de vidas que se
han perdido debido esta pandemia y
resaltar la importancia de poder
prevenirlo desde 1987 1990 y 88 se hace
el primer día de acción contra el sida
como se llama hoy y no hay realmente una
razón especial porque se escoge el
primero de siempre más allá de la
atención que podría recibir a través de
los medios y que estaba lo
suficientemente lejos de las
celebraciones de diciembre ahora ya tu
pregunta cómo se contagia el vih el vih
se transmite a través del intercambio de
líquidos corporales
con la persona infectada entonces
principalmente lo que es sangre leche
materna semen secreciones vaginales
también se puede transmitir de la madre
al niño durante el embarazo del parto y
es muy importante entender que no se
transmite con un abrazo con un beso con
intercambiar comida o un apretón de mano
entonces en ese sentido para poder
prevenir la transmisión hay unos
aspectos que son esenciales en primer
lugar usar los preservativos
en segundo es tratar de mejorar las
pruebas de detección y el acceso a estas
pruebas de detección y el asesoramiento
después de que es diagnosticado el virus
tercer lugar tenemos tratamientos que
sirven y estos tratamientos también
ayudan a reducir la transmisión entonces
es importante tener acceso a esos
tratamientos
en cuarto lugar hay que vigilar cómo se
utilizan las jeringas en los
consumidores de drogas inyectables y
tratar de facilitar y manejar esto como
un problema de salud pública
también el cuidado de las madres de las
mujeres embarazadas evitar la
transmisión del vih al niño y también se
habla de que las circunstacias posición
en los hombres podría ayudar aunque esto
todavía se tiene que confirmar entonces
hay varias formas en que se puede
reducir la transmisión y estos son los
aspectos claves para poder manejar esta
pandemia hola doctor en los saludos
feliz miércoles si le quiere preguntar
entonces en la actualidad para tratar el
vih y evitar llegar así ya tenemos solo
tratamientos antiretrovirales cómo
funcionan estos tratamientos
si tenemos unos tratamientos que
realmente han hecho que si recordamos
hace unas décadas en el vih era como una
sentencia de muerte
básicamente la enfermedad se
desarrollaba muy rápidamente no teníamos
medicamentos desde esos primeros casos
en 1982 que fueron descritos en eeuu y
en francia aunque históricamente parece
que el primer caso ocurre en 1959 desde
entonces en los finales de los 80 y
durante los 90 vimos un desarrollo en el
término de tratamientos de medicamentos
y esos son los antirretrovirales y
tenemos 5 diferentes tipos o grupos
grandes de antirretrovirales y lo que
hacen estos medicamentos es atacar el
proceso los mecanismos del virus en
diferentes fases por eso se utilizan
entonces en combinación para poder
atacarlo de diferentes formas y su
objetivo principal es ayudar a mantener
la función inmunológica poder ayudarnos
a mantener las defensas ayudar a las
personas que tienen vih a mantener sus
defensas en los niños puede ayudar a
revertir problemas de crecimiento o
evitar los problemas de crecimiento y
prevenir las infecciones oportunistas
que eran las que anteriormente estaban
muy presentes y que ahora hemos visto
que han pasado quizás a un segundo plano
también ayuda a reducir la transmisión
que reduce la carga viral y eso permite
también evitar que pase de una persona
con vih a otra persona y estos
tratamientos han ido avanzando a grandes
pasos y han hecho que esa enfermedad que
era una sentencia de muerte ahora mismo
se ha convertido en una enfermedad
crónica y manejable doctor un pequeño
dato ahí también se calcula que en las
últimas décadas gracias a los
tratamientos se han ahorrado las muertes
de 16 millones de personas entonces no
es una cifra menor vemos que este acceso
a las terapias en donde estar como
comentaba el doctor es muy importante
pero sigue sin ser equitativo por
ejemplo en europa y en eeuu más del 80%
de las personas que viven con vih tienen
acceso a estos antirretrovirales esa
cifra es significativamente menor por
ejemplo en el continente africano donde
sólo el 66 por ciento de las personas
que viven con vih tienen acceso a este
tipo de tratamientos entonces le
pregunto doctor no que impact tiene que
estos tratamientos que existen no pueden
llegar a todo el mundo que los necesita
si tenemos tratamientos que sirven
tenemos unos tratamientos muy buenos
tenemos medidas preventivas que son
excelentes sin embargo seguimos viendo
estas desigualdades que existen en
desigualdades económicas geográficas y
también de género por eso este año en el
día mundial de la acción contra el sida
el lema es pone fin a las déficit a las
desigualdades un fin al sida y pon fin a
las pandemias porque hemos visto que
estas desigualdades también han afectado
por ejemplo ahora mismo en la pandemia
de kobe 19 en el acceso a las vacunas
por ejemplo entonces estamos viendo que
los países más afectados pues no tienen
un sistema de salud lo suficientemente
fuerte no tienen acceso a los
medicamentos necesarios tampoco pueden
monitorear si este tratamiento se está
haciendo tampoco a buenos exámenes y
pruebas de laboratorio que puedan
diagnosticar a tiempo la infección y por
eso es tan importante que en los
próximos años podamos hacer de una
manera mucho más solidaria una inversión
en estos países donde todavía el vih
continua
afectando muchísimas personas y poder
garantizar que estas personas tengan
acceso al tratamiento como siempre al
final la lucha por la igualdad sigue
siendo uno de los temas que siempre
tratamos no algo muy preocupante sin
embargo es que se han detectado algunas
resistencias no estos tratamientos
antiretrovirales específicamente a los
yens nrc que son ampliamente usados en
países precisamente de ingresos bajos y
se ha descubierto que el 10% por ejemplo
de las personas previamente incluso
antes de contraer el virus ya han
desarrollado resistencia a este tipo de
tratamientos y en la población infantil
ese porcentaje puede llegar al 50 por
ciento entonces pues eso puede ser un
problema doctor muy grande no sé si hay
alguna solución que podemos hacer frente
a esto
si la clave aquí es el acceso al
medicamento porque vemos que cuando los
medicamentos se toman de manera
irregular cuando no se siguen los
tratamientos de manera adecuada es
cuando el virus puede mutar aún mejor
adaptarse mejor aún contra estos
tratamientos y ocurre la resistencia y
este problema de resistencia hemos visto
que ha ido aumentando y ha aumentado en
todo con el tiempo entonces es esencial
garantizar el acceso al medicamento no
solamente que se tenga acceso al
medicamento sino que ese se tome de
manera regular y como estar prescrito y
adicionalmente desarrollar nuevos
medicamentos que se puedan utilizar y
que tengan bajo costo porque como tú
decías la mayoría de la resistencia está
ocurriendo en los países de menor
ingreso que están utilizando
medicamentos que tienen acceso pero que
van a están desarrollando una
resistencia contra estos estados
entonces es esencial desarrollar estos
nuevos medicamentos y garantizar el
tratamiento regular y la adherencia al
tratamiento por parte de los pacientes
doctores yo también lo hablaba hace
minutos porque es tan difícil
desarrollar una vacuna contra el vih en
que van todas estas investigaciones
tengo entendido la farmacéutica moderna
ya está en desarrollo de esta vacuna nos
vamos a morir y no tener la vacuna o
vamos a alcanzar a verla antes de
morirnos
ojalá que no yo creo que es posible y
hay algunas personas están haciendo unas
predicciones de que quizás para el 2023
2024 tengamos una vacuna que sirva hemos
visto que la capacidad de la ciencia y
la tecnología ha incrementado muchísimo
los últimos años entonces esperamos que
ojalá podamos tener una vacuna que sirva
durante nuestras vidas
es un virus muy difícil de manejar de
poder hacer una vacuna cambia mucho
entonces son virus que que cambian que
mutan muy frecuentemente va cambiando va
cambiando entonces cualquier vacuna que
se utilice el virus lo evita la esquiva
por así decirlo esquiva los anticuerpos
entonces ha sido muy difícil desarrollar
vacunas contra él contra este virus
contra el vih pero es posible que en un
futuro gracias a la tecnología gracias a
los cambios podemos tener una vacuna que
se sirva y ojalá esas noticias de
modernas desde otros laboratorios que
están diciendo están avisando que están
teniendo buenos resultados puedan llevar
una vacuna que sirva en 2023 2024 si
siempre estamos esperando dar buenas
noticias entonces estaremos pendientes
de cómo avanzan estas investigaciones
vamos a hablar un momento también del
vih población infantil como comentaba el
doctor los niños pueden contraer este
virus si la madre está embarazada o en
el momento del parto está contagiada y
tiene una carga viral transmisible en
estos casos puede ser más difícil de
detectar en este tipo de evaluación por
ejemplo el 40 por ciento de los niños
con vih vive sin estar diagnosticado y
el 60% viven sin tener una carga viral
la suprimida es decir que pueden seguir
contagiando a otras personas doctor cómo
afecta el vih cómo afecta también la
enfermedad del sida a la población
infantil
tenemos más o menos 1.8 dos millones de
niños con el vih en el mundo ahora mismo
la principal el principal método de
transmisión es a través del embarazo en
el parto donde ocurre la mayoría
entonces es muy importante para la
prevención del vih para que nos lleve a
los niños es muy importante la
prevención en la salud materna los
controles prenatales el diagnóstico en
las mujeres embarazadas luego
asegurarnos de que en caso de que la
madre tenga vih entonces se busca una
una cesárea en la que el parto sea lo
más que se evite lo máximo posible el
contacto o el riesgo de la transmisión y
luego también se recomienda evitar la
leche materna luego en estos niños de
madres con vih entonces es esencial
hacer el diagnóstico lo antes posible
pero tampoco tan temprano porque los
exámenes pueden no ser lo
suficientemente sensibles en las
primeras semanas de vida entonces se
recomienda un pcr al mes y tres meses
después
embargo estos son exámenes que son
costosos y que algunos países pues no
tienen acceso o geográficamente no se
puede llegar al laboratorio para poder
hacer el diagnóstico
en los niños también se ha visto que el
desarrollo de la infección es mucho más
rápido que es más rápido que los adultos
entonces es muy importante
diagnosticarlo tiempo y tratar de
monitorear y llevar el tratamiento de
los niños ella para para terminar
también acerca de los niños es muy
importante entender también que los
niños dependen de su familia entonces el
tratamiento debe enfocarse también al
núcleo familiar ya que son los
familiares los que recogen el
tratamiento y garantiza que los niños lo
puedan recibir y por último en los niños
muchos niños se han visto afectados
porque sus padres han muerto entonces
son huérfanos de personas que han
fallecido por el vih entonces tenemos
que el vih está afectando a los niños en
diferentes formas directa e
indirectamente doctor pues muchas
gracias por toda esta información me
gustaría terminar solo diciendo que en
verdad la lucha contra esta epidemia no
está tan mal hemos logrado bastantes de
los objetivos que nos proponíamos
entonces pues esperamos poder seguir
dando buenas también con usted y aquí en
el espacio de salud así es más
muchísimas gracias entonces por esa
información también por supuesto a usted
doctor por toda la información que nos
brindó acerca del vih/sida hasta aquí
llegamos con este